dado el poco tiempo que queda para la
salida de donald trump someterlo en
segundo juicio político tendría
consecuencias legales serias o se trata
más de un acto simbólico por parte de
los demócratas y las consecuencias de un
juicio político primero buenas noches en
las consecuencias de un juicio político
siempre son políticas o sea no son
legales
entonces no no sí sí la cámara de
representantes vote los artículos de
peter o no
todavía los fiscales lo pueden enjuiciar
después que se vaya del cargo a trump
pero si lo que me está preguntando es si
pienso que llegar a una condena sería
muy difícil con diez días que faltan en
el mandato de trump que logren el
miércoles reciben votar los artículos el
artículo y después mandarlo al senado y
que el senado en este momento monte un
juicio con debido al proceso duro que lo
podrán terminar en suficiente tiempo
ahora cree que queda una acción optará
por perdonarse a sí mismo como lo ha
sugerido en repetidas ocasiones y una
vez esté fuera de la casa blanca que
posee
las consecuencias se enfrenta a donald
trump como usted lo dijo a lo mejor con
los fiscales y estamos especulando pero
si yo estoy de la opinión de yo soy de
la opinión de que trump va a ser hacer
un auto perdón se va a perdonar y lo va
a ser porque lo puede hacer o por lo
menos él piensa que lo puede hacer
todavía no se ha aprobado eso en los
tribunales y es posible que se probaría
a iu pero yo creo que sí
así emite el auto perdón y después sale
del mandato todavía va a tener riesgos
legales o sea hay investigaciones
actuales hay una investigación actual en
la fiscalidad donde yo trabajaba en un
entonces más rata me desempeñé ahí a
través de nueve años como fiscal ellos
lo están investigando por fraude y
evasión fiscal por cosas que hizo cuando
era negocio cuando te empresario antes
de ser presidente y aparte yo creo que
las autoridades de georgia lo van a
investigar también para esa llamada
famosa que hizo el bien de semana pasado
con los funcionarios de georgia por un
tipo de extorsión
así que esas investigaciones van a
seguir y es posible que se monten
investigaciones federales sobre la
insurrección y sobre otras cosas que ha
hecho que posiblemente violen las leyes
de los estados unidos